[Music]
so food prices have risen so much it's
pushed up our grocery bills you wonder
how that changes the calculus for
actually going out to eat as opposed to
cooking at home right and we will always
take an excuse to not cook yes it brings
us back to the basics of new york a
slice of pizza let's check out champion
pizza
with its original store opening in 2009
champion pizza has grown into an
award-winning celebrity attracting
bonafide new york slice of life a labor
of love for its owner hockey octanes you
own five pizza stores in new york city
yes i do and and how are things going as
we head into 2022
what do you think
the cost for everything must be going up
and you must be feeling it yeah i mean i
show you guys what are these what are we
looking at here so this is the company
concorde that i buy supplies from them
uh since 2010 and it's been almost 12
years
the same company same supply same food
everything same only different as the
price
inflation in action
the pepperoni how much was like
pepperoni sliced here is three dollars
89 cents per unit right now is a 544
yeah each pound
i use like almost like every day like
i'm a 20 pound
that cost me almost seven dollars the
pepperoni alone yeah just pepperoni
production snags and lack of competition
have driven up meat prices labor
shortages and increased shipping rates
have made tomatoes more costly and
droughts heavy rain and deep freezes
slammed wheat crops that pushed flower
prices up all of these factors have duly
affected the humble slice
are you charging more for your pizza uh
not the price is the same i couldn't
change the price
the sx pizza shop i increased like 50
cent but for the kids i couldn't change
it because
they don't have money so it's still one
dollar
you know last you know like believe it
or not uh i save money for my son to
college i take
all his money in college
so you use your savings
i took everything i just put my business
when you're having to make such tough
personal decisions how do you not just
say
guys i'm not doing dollar slices anymore
you need to pay two dollars that's why
you know like i keep my customer if i
play with something i'm so scared that
i'm gonna lose what i have consistent
pricing isn't just a business decision
for hockey it's a personal one from a
guy who had a tough journey and wants to
give back
so hackie you know a lot about flat
bread because
this is something that you liked eating
when you were a child growing up right
yeah in turkey in turkey i still work
like 11 and turkish pizza shop i learned
a lot over there and about the dough so
i come to new york in 2001 january 28th
and i have 240 in my pocket i don't
speak word of english and two weeks
later i become homeless and i met one
guy he's from senegal his name ronnie he
speak franchise but he was homeless as
well
so he take me to baudi mission as a
homeless shelter on baudi as the the
hottest thing in the world okay to be
homeless no one choose to become
homeless believe that guys no one
when you don't have money as one dollar
is your net worth it's your everything
and one dollar for them is like a
million dollars the first paycheck when
i get paid
i want a bathroom and i said thank you
god thank you for everything all right i
cry a lot and that's partly your
thinking behind why you're keeping your
prices the way they are yeah one hundred
percent keep it accessible for people am
i gonna change it you'd rather close
stores than raise your prices yes
even i have one store i still could
survive and take in my family and you
know send my kids in school like i could
still survive to work in behind my
content
hard work and love drives a lot of small
business owners like hockey
but what's driving his customers is
simply the love for great pizza
wow
oh my god
i mean this is all my favorite food this
looks amazing that one is lasagna what's
your favorite one out of all these to
eat i usually eat this one or this one
yeah either one you like the burrata
yeah i love brotha but you know like
it's just too much a little bit you know
something yeah if you want to be healthy